okay leute herzlich willkommen zum neuen
video ich wurde von maxim seiner erstes
mal challenge gepäck erstes mal
challenge heißt das ganze youtuber die
dazu nominiert werden sind aufgefordert
sieben dinge in einem video zu tun die
sie davor noch niemals gemacht haben und
zwar an dominiere ich luca com kräfte
als erstes und meinen eigenen bruder
escape ich saß schon eine beide da und
hab mir gedanken gemacht und es ist
einfach nur scheiße rausgekommen also an
alle leute die ein sinnvolles video
erwarten den mann sinnvolle dinge zum
erst am 8 es ist vielleicht nicht für
euch habe aldi sehen wollen wie sich ein
mittlerweile 21 jähriger volksmassen
macht und peinliche dinge tut das könnte
was für euch sein deswegen sag nummer
eins sagt nummer eins ist absolut
großartig weil ich mir gerade die haare
gemacht habe und zwar ich sachen nummer
eins auf meiner wunderschönen liste für
die erstes mal stellen
ich habe bisher noch nie in meinem leben
mit einem motorradhelm auf dem kopf
im pitch sprache geredet fit ist der
junge mann sehr verehrten damen und
herren das ist die piste mein name ist
der baustelle poker und ich hab's dir
ganz herzlich begrüßen dollar 19 hier in
der ersten show vom tag auch paris st
fischer genannt und mein visier ist voll
dreck erste nachricht kommt von das ist
die erste nachricht kommen von
wetterstationen die sagen
borsch heiße partie rufen kann ja ja ok
ja wir sind kalt life hat eine schnauze
ok weiter als scheiße
nummer zwei auf der glorreichen liste
der dinge die ich noch nie getan habe in
meinem leben eine banane in die
mikrowelle gepackt kommen sie mit
alles was sie benötigen ist ein sohn und
eine mikrowelle ich solche flächen
theologin
was ist eigentlich schlimmste was
passieren kann wenn so ein überladener
in der mikrowelle ist ich habe jetzt
einfach mal was ich habe den timer auf
vier minuten gestellt
er soll passieren was passieren die
leute so weit das ding explodiert
berechnet ab sag's euch von ich bin mega
nah dran mit meinem gesicht
schäfer ich schon die ganzen kommentare
der applaus wollte verschwand des awo
heute macht euch keine sorgen denn keine
lebensmittel verschwendet diese ballade
war schon alt und vergammelt hat sich
freiwillig für dieses experiment
angemeldet so lange sicht auch komisch
eine minute ist das ding drin
es ist mega adam brutzeln drin aber ich
habe so eine banane explodiert nicht
okay sagen wir schauen mal kurz rein
ich denke ich gar nicht so schlecht
nummer 3 auf meine glorreichen liste der
dinge die ich gemacht habe in meinem
leben ich habe noch nie meinen
autoschlüssel in den müll geworfen
es ist faszinierend was dieses video
einen neuen geistigen höhen erreicht als
unfassbar die welt ist schockiert die
welt ist begeistert genauso wie von
sache 4
ich habe noch nie auf einem hobart
geblockt
in new york city die spiegelberger ist
das jetzt noch das coaching
okay leute wie soll ich euch das sagen
machen was kurz und schmerzvoll ich habe
noch nie vor laufender kamera ein bier
giggs ist ja leute dass ich absolut
dafür bin dass sich über gute vorbilder
sind deswegen zum wohl effekt so oft
dass mich für diese aktion so ungefähr
alle hassen werden ist wird es mega
viele gm die schreiben oh mein gott
er hat schon ein tropfen bier in seinem
leben getrunken um dann wird sie anderen
geben die regelmäßig saufen sagen was er
kann er überhaupt nicht echsen weil ich
so was nie mache aber leute seid ihr mit
mir die versuche einfach
lediglich einmal drin ist das ist
ungefähr der beste beweis dafür dass ich
so was auch hinter der kamera nicht
mache ich aber total schlechteren bin
aber schneiden wieder angenehmer ich
habe um euch auch eine chance zu geben
in dem video zu seiner gefragt was ich
selbst noch nie gemacht habe und da
kamen tolle vorschläge zum beispiel mit
apple komplett rasur gesicht arme beine
aber eigentlich an der vorschlag war
auch dabei von starcom pastor und zwar
meint er red hot chili peppers beim
kacken gehört
7 wird sie richtig richtig hart nachdem
ich mir gerade eben andere flüssigkeit
angezündet habe denn nummer sieben ist
ich bin noch nie im haus sei gesprochen
jetzt teil springen im vollen magen im
halben liter bier
das wird richtig schön okay leute hier
ist das arbeitsgerät waren schon 20
minuten seien spenden jetzt noch mal
kurz schnell oft schneller wie lange
eigentlich der sinn von erstes mal
challenge mein bauch als plastik vinny
prospal denke